نحن لم نستسلم ننتصر او نمت ولا تظنوا
انها النهايه سوف نقابل الجيل القدم
والاجيال
القادمه ما تعرضت له غزه في الحرب الحاليه
احدث خسائر غير مسبوقه في الارواح فقد
تجاوزت حصيله الشهداء عتبه ال الفا وتحولت
الشوارع والاسواق الى مقابر جماعيه
وانهارت المنظومه الصحيه والتعليميه
والبنيه التحتيه فما المكاسب التي حققتها
حماس في حربها مع اسرائيل في تقرير نشرته
مجله فورن بوليسي كتب الباحثان الامريكيان
دانيل بايمان وديلان داف ان هجوم حماس
تسبب في ايلام اسرائيل وتحطيم احساسها
بالامن ووفق الباحثين نجح هجوم المقاومه
في السابع من اكتوبر في خداع نتنياهو
والمنظومه الامنيه الاسرائيليه التي كانت
على يقين من ان الحركه ليست لديها النيه
ولا القدرات لازمه لشن هجوم واسع النطاق
الهجوم ترك ندوبا نفسيه عميقه لدى
الاسرائيليين بسبب اخفاق الاستخبارات في
توقعه وهو ما اجبر تل ابيب على اعاده
تقييم نهجها في التعامل مع الامن في
المستقبل اما على الصعيد الدولي فقد نجحت
الحركه في اعاده القضيه الفلسطينيه الى
الواجهه بعد ان نسيها العالم او كاد
واوقفت محادثات التطبيع التي تدعمها
الولايات المتحده بين اسرائيل ودول اخرى
زد على ذلك ان رد اسرائيل على هجوم حماس
عزز حقيقه ما تفعله اسرائيل سواء في غزه
المحاصره او في الضفه المحتله من انها قوه
احتلال غاشمه تقمع الفلسطينيين بوحشيه
وتفرض حصارا خانقا على غزه فاقم الازمه
الانسانيه وهو ما يقوض صورتها لدى الراي
العام العالمي وعلى المدى الطويل فان
مشاهد القتل والدمار التي لن تمحى من
مخيله اطفال غزه وشبابها ستعزز في نفوسهم
الرغبه في الانتقام من
اسرائيل اما على الصعيد الداخلي الفلسطيني
فراى الباحثان ان حماس استعادت مؤهلات
المقاومه بين الشعب الفلسطيني اذ تشير
استطلاعات الراي في غزه والضفه الغربيه
الى وجود دعم شعبي قوي للهجوم وينظر
الفلسطينيون الى صفقه تبادل الاسرى على
انها انتصار ضح للحركه التي بات بامكانها
ان تجادل وتقول ان هجماتها وليس مفاوضات
السلطه الفلسطينيه هي التي ادت الى تحرير
الاسرى في الغرب الاوروبي والامريكي اظهرت
الحرب دعما ملحوظا للقضيه وللكف الشعب
الفلسطيني ولا سما بعد ان عمت المظاهرات
المؤيده للفلسطينيين انحاء اوروبا
وباستثناء قليله تبنى جنوب العالم السرديه
الفلسطينيه فصورت الحرب على انها حرب دوله
قويه تهجم على شعب اعزل ورغم ضخامه
الخسائر غير المسبوقه في تاريخ الشعب
الفلسطيني يرى البعض ان معظم حركات التحرر
الوطني في العالم حققت نجاحاتها الكبرى
بعد تصعيد عسكري عقبته خسائر بشريه كبيره
لحقت بالاساس بالمدنيين مثل ما حدث
للفيتناميين مع الامريكيين اذ وصلت خسائر
الفيتناميين البشريه في بعض التقديرات الى
ثلاثه ملايين وقبلها خلال ثوره الشعب
الجزائري على فرنسا تلك الثوره التي
استمرت عقودا واستشهد فيها مليون ونصف
مليون شهيد لكنها كللت في النهايه
باستقلال البلاد عن
[موسيقى]
فرنسا